il ne reste plus que 30 minutes avant
l'ouverture des portes pas question de
rater l'occasion de participer mais pas
où va 12h30 à chaque jour puis on va
voir du monde 6 4 avant pour normand au
but ses copines
même si elles sont très occupés c'est un
incontournable
on attend que ça où on vient te laisse
faire ce soir c'est la chasse à l'as de
coeur une loterie communautaires
organisés pour subventionner un projet
collectif à inkerman on veut financer la
reconstruction d'un pont et 110 des
chats ça lasse il y en a dans les quatre
provinces de l'atlantique
un phénomène qui prend de l'ampleur au
nouveau brunswick par exemple on est
passé de 3 loterie en 2014 à 114 en 2018
chaque semaine via est tiré il gagnant
repart avec une partie des recettes
récoltées dans les sept derniers jours
le gagnant 0,6 une tiare quand un paquet
comme celui ci et si j'ai choisi l'as de
coeur
il empoche le gros lot
tant que là ce n'a pas été tiré la
chasse se poursuit un suspense qui peut
donc durer cinquante deux semaines
de quoi animer la petite communauté de
600 personnes c'est la fébrilité est
d'un type la commune comme ce que je
vois pas ce que j'entends c'est le
trafic trafic continue est une vie au
quotidien les mardis nacré du jury
normand achètent des billets pour sa
fille et sa mère le gros lot aujourd'hui
s'élève à plus de 2 5 millions de
dollars on est toujours tous les trois
ans depuis j'en prends deux de 28 et les
séries différentes
[Musique]
certains viennent de loin une record
carottes monde est à peu près d'une
quarantaine d'années d'autres achètent
de nombreux billets évidemment nous
sommes d'argent qu'il ne vient pas des
gros groupes là je peux parler d'un coup
il est presque 18 heures et les ventes
n'arrête pas on est rendu à peu près de
223 mais depuis ma tendre
c'est une journée ça c'est juste
aujourd'hui le bureau de vente est sur
le point de fermer les derniers
acheteurs se précipitent ont diverses
les billets vendus cette semaine une
routine bien vu
norma et patiente regarde le tirage en
direct la vie va continuer ce n'est pas
un jour de chance pour norma mais elle
continuera de participer telle
excitation c'est qui les fans continue
parce qu'on a hâte de voir ces puits les
chanceux ce soir une famille de dix
personnes qui sont assurés de repartir
avec cent cinquante six mille dollars à
partager jusqu'au bout
il restait dix cartes il doit piger l'as
de coeur pour repartir avec en plus 2 5
millions de dollars
[Musique]
c'est une demie chance place de coeur
est resté sur la table l'achat se
poursuit ici elisa ferreira du canada
inc e mail
[Musique]